this where will we be without ricky
gervais where would we be without Ricky
Gervais did you see opening one
worthless love it it's not just ruthless
here's what it is it is what it is it is
it is this is it this is it what do I
say a lot that the people make [ __ ]
memes of that yeah I'm not going to do
that I'm not gonna okay so when I how
about this I know but I want you to hit
me every time I say that nope
smack me in the arm as hard as you can
what is this leave some shirts in the
making but please keep saying okay this
is it as a comedian you you write jokes
and you go oh I can't say that because
it's so offensive or it's gonna hurt
them or this and that and it just shows
you the freedom in which he does his art
form by it's completely fearless there's
he doesn't care about the consequences
and he's doing it in front of the elite
Hollywood establishment he's a beer and
he has a beer in hand and he's just just
so there's not anyone funnier I don't
think when it comes to shying away from
I think you know bill Bert Khanna does
it marked kind of does it Rogen does it
you know I have a story about Rogen in a
second remind me but what he did on the
Golden Globes was just and he's done it
every time every time he does it Golden
Globes I always double down this really
especially the the whole like Jeffrey
Epstein saying like you didn't kill
himself and everything and then he
followed up with oh I'm sorry he was
your friend yeah yeah I mean I mean
that's actually true like oh he's
basically calling out there there's
photos
yeah even how light the DiCaprio jerk
was he followed up with Prince Andrew I
think further did double down he doubled
downs you know the Judi Dench joke which
was insane it's insane and then you
thought it was already bad cuz you know
you you have an image of Dame Judi Dench
like eating her own [ __ ] right but then
he doubles down by like coughing and
saying ooh like fur balls right she's
old school he's old school
and then he doubled triples down honey
attacks the company's right Apple when
they're what's at the stops yeah he was
there right there yeah and it's like
he's in the [ __ ] room and you'd said
it yeah and all these streaming devices
gigantic companies do have sweatshops
and whatnot or across the country and
it's just crazy he said it to their
faces and he doesn't care yeah and I
love that he was like get up here
receive your little small award and [ __ ]
off don't share any of you like your
political [ __ ] and then people
started doing their political [ __ ] I
mean when what Keynes about the animals
I get it well what Keynes said the same
he I loved what he said up front he was
like who gives a [ __ ] this is like we
all know that this is like a [ __ ]
award show this doesn't mean anything
it's just people making money off this
pretend competition yeah really there's
no there's no five categories and 5
people contestants and that I don't
watch the whole thing there are but he's
just saying like what's the point of it
yeah like we're all good oh yeah
statement to them like this is all joke
it's a joke that everyone's good yeah
yeah and everyone has their own muscles
that they do you know people you know
people Brad Pitt for instance you know I
think he's a great [ __ ] actor and he
deserves
he's Golden Globe I think he is do you
ever see that [ __ ] Coen Brothers
movie which one burn after yes he's so
[ __ ] funny in that my brother and I I
made my brother and I watch it in
Arizona and my brother and I were
laughing so hard at his scenes he is
very funny and in onesome at a time in
Hollywood he's also very funny in it so
is Leal he's incredible in it but then
it's talked about Joe Rogan real quick
yes wait we have to congratulate I know
that the Golden Globes we just [ __ ] on
it but Aquafina did win Best Actor I
think that's something to be proud of
since
aquafina was a guest and she will
probably do it again on tiger belly
she's our family member and honestly
there are there are those Asian people
if they became successful in that way
that I would go into a rage and I'm
sorry that's my honest
what's the list I'm not gonna tell but
that's my honest opinion she is not one
of them I swear to [ __ ] god when she
won that thing I was like God thank God
because she's so good for area I love
her John Cho if he ever want anything
I'd be so [ __ ] happy for him I love
him so much
process of elimination keep telling us
you have the positive ones oh if Daniel
Dae Kim ever won an Emmy or anything
that I would like nut in my pants and do
a jog around my little backyard right
and I would come kiss my cats okay if
Margaret Cho ever won anything I mean I
would [ __ ] a drill a hole in the wall
and [ __ ] it I was gonna put in a [ __ ] it
right who else
if Jimmy o yang ever worrying thing I'd
be jealous oh but I love know he's got
one of them though he's not one of these
not one of them that's why I said I love
him yeah but I would be a little jealous
cuz he's younger
you know min but I think that there's
something very interesting about him
well so does my list go to if Sandro
want anything yes that's congratulations
congratulations you deserve it grace
Park congratulations it's all the
information that's the only information
that you get oh here's another one
Ronny Chang Chang I love him Ronny Chang
is named from the daily daily yeah yeah
I love him but those are the ones I
think that's about it Sheng Wang okay